[music]
at this hour of the threat without an intermediary
land Diz on the side of the Republic of Belarus,
then the dorsal group there is
unstoppable Rhubarb socks are often crossed in
order to bring down that of their defense with the
possibility of meat this our defense
with striking strength in skill is built to
conduct an offensive day, therefore, for
in order to equip our tank
brigades, all the tanks are nothing
[music]
pass on to Bradley
then plus it’s a Swedish bone yes an infantry fighting vehicle
so it works it can go out directly and
work it against tanks
as the infantry will behave themselves Naturally
they hide behind us behind these
[music]